Spoiler alert, but in case you didn't know,
the fourth episode of Game of Thrones' final
season was distressing in more ways than one.
Viewers witnessed two deaths, a long-awaited
romance scene that was ruined just a few scenes
later, and a moment of abandonment that broke
a million hearts.
Suffice to say, Thrones fans were none too
happy with episode 4, and things might get
even worse when they realize why the episode
was titled "The Last of the Starks."
Watching the latest Game of Thrones installment,
the answer seems obvious: The episode takes
its title from a line of dialogue Arya Stark
gives during a conversation with Sansa, Bran,
and Jon.
"We're family.
The four of us.
The last of the Starks."
Easy explanation, right?
Sure, but PureWow has offered up a deeper
significance to Arya's words and to the title
of episode 4.
Arya, Sansa, and Bran do represent the last
living members of House Stark that fans know
of, but Jon isn't technically a Stark.
Though his mother is Lyanna Stark, Jon belongs
to House Targaryen, having taken the last
name of his father Rhaegar Targaryen.
And if Jon has children, according to the
rules of Westeros, they too would be Targaryens.
With Jon out of the count for the last of
the living Starks, that leaves us with just
three true-born children of Ned and Catelyn
Stark who have survived the brutality of political
warfare over the course of the series.
Some pretty big issues arise here.
Bran has made it clear on several occasions
that not only is he not really a Stark anymore,
it's arguable whether he's even still human.
And in episode 4, he reiterates this in a
conversation with Tyrion, making it very clear
that he no longer considers himself the Stark
heir.
"I'm not lord of Winterfell."
"You're the only surviving trueborn son of
Ned Stark."
"You don't want it."
"I don't really want anymore."
It seems unlikely at this point that Bran
will ever produce an heir.
After all, he no longer wants anything.
That leaves just Arya and Sansa as the last
of the Starks.
But it also seems highly unlikely that Arya
will continue the Stark line either.
Once, it seemed possible:
"I've never had a family."
"I can be your family."
But in this episode, Arya showed just how
much she has changed, gently but firmly rejecting
Gendry's marriage proposal.
And any lady will be lucky to have you.
But I'm not a lady.
I never have been.
Arya isn't about creating new life.
She serves the god of death now.
And in episode 4, she strongly hinted that
her days as a Stark, and possibly her days
among the living, were coming to an end.
"You're heading to King's Landing?"
"I have some unfinished business."
"Me too."
"I don't plan on coming back."
"Neither do I."
So could Sansa actually be the last of the
Starks?
She's already the Lady of Winterfell, and
that could remain true, as she might have
children who bear the Stark name rather than
her husband's name.
Yes, children in Westeros usually take their
father's last name, but there are exceptions
when it comes to noble lines: Lady Lyanna
Mormont, for instance, inherited both her
family name and title from her mother, Lady
Maege Mormont.
Even if Sansa were to die before having an
heir, it's unlikely that the long and famous
Stark line would be allowed to die out.
After thousands of years of rule, the Starks
have intermarried with and are related to
all the other major noble families of the
north, most notably the Karstarks and the
Umbers.
Of course, both of these lines were apparently
ended forever by the Night King's army, but
there are no doubt other distant cousins with
Stark blood who could take up the wolf banner
of Winterfell if needed.
And it would be needed.
After all, as Lyanna once famously said,
"We know no king but the King in the North,
whose name is Stark"
And that remains true even if the last Stark
isn't a king at all… but rather a Queen.
"What if there's someone else?
Someone better?"
All hail the last of the Starks?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.